but Carmelo watching this crowd react to
seeing you here tonight you've just got
the loudest cheers what was that like
for you
energy is always always good in this
building
I have some great years in the Chosin
and I look forward to coming back and
playing this girl to some more so but
the integer is always good defenders
always been good fans as always you know
been good to me too this is home my
family is here friends is here so you
can't beat this energy coach miss Doane
was saying that you've just been a
nightmare to try to plan for over the
years and try to stop over the years he
was happy to have you in the building
another one of those guys Dwyane Wade I
know you're here to support him tonight
what does that mean to watch him play it
means a lot because it was it was very
difficult for me to come out the house
they come to our NBA game so but if it
was one moment that I could come out and
be here on in this seat is to come see
him you know finish it out here in the
guards last game
knowing where he fought to this game
know when he's continued to do like it
he is much Deeping a basketball when it
comes to us